aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter le
jeu le plus nul du monde bon j'avoue été
facile quand tu viens d'avoir un jeu
déjà tu sais qu'il est pourri en
fonction de quelques trucs vos
premièrement le nom quand jeu s'appelle
ricochet tu juste pas [ __ ] merde
c'était pas tout après avoir acheté le
jeu et avoir une langue et même plutôt
bizarre tu vas le télécharger forcément
et là là ça craint allez hop c'est parti
installations après tain je l'aï dit
jouer un nouveau jeu bon alors que
benneteau a de quoi mais c'est quoi ce
délire
je peux déjà les jouets bon petit
troisième détail auquel on fera
attention le nombre de serveurs
disponibles en jeu qui est quand même
assez pitoyable quoi est due cette
saveur mer le jeu kébili d' et enfin
l'écran d'accueil du jeu là et leur jeu
épique
j'aimerais juste revenir sur le nom par
genre le mec a créé le jeu
enfin c'est ça s'est passé comment fait
quoi il a eu l'idée de dates d'affilée
ça comme ça fâche c'est pas du gâteau
filaction je peux faire un jeu là je
m'arrête est pas capable d ridicule l'a
arrêté sur c'est quoi je vais pas m'en
sépare et chacun des quais ricochet ces
erreurs comme ça je vais l'appeler dieu
tient donc le jeu possède trois couleurs
pas trois millions trois couleurs donc
le bleu le rouge et le jaune mais trois
couleurs le maire et quelques dérives et
donc plus ou moins clairs plus ou moins
foncée plus ou moins de contraste donc
le but du jeu c'est quoi c'est ce que
vous attendez tous ces faits début
annoncé alors vous n'êtes pas d'armes
à moins que les 10 tu sois des armes je
sais pas donc vous vous déplacez deux
plateformes en plateformes et le but est
de lancer et 10 sur vos adversaires pour
qu'il tombe des plateformes
je pense que ce scénario a été créée par
fitch de genre
bon c'est vrai que les développeurs
auraient fait quelques efforts pour la
cinématique genre si vous tombez d'une
plateforme dans le vide
vous vous retrouvez avec ça sur votre
écran j'ai tourné
enfin j'ai pas moi au bout d'une heure
de jeu déjà si tu tiens une heure sur ce
jeu je te faire ici ah bon tu dois être
dans un état mais est dingue je pense
que ça doit être un truc pas loin de sa
valeur
oui je voulais juste imaginer si à
l'époque il y avait des décès le dr fait
arrêter le délire
découvrez maintenant ricochet problème
désormais disponible à la modeste somme
de 4 euros vous est passé de l'état
petits cailloux à l'état grand caillou
une nouvelle couleur exclusive qui vous
fera penser à fantasmes entité plus fous
de rose un incroyable du british duty
maintenant je suis là à un nouveau
disque de couleur verte qui me fait
avancer votre talent vous préférez et
enfin une nouvelle carte sur laquelle
vous ferez tués
encore plus rapidement les gauchers
premium disponible dès maintenant
et peut-être qu'ils aient des lataniers
puck sur ce jeu et l'âme sur ce jeu
rendez vous compte
alors attention marcel c'est
actuellement l'air très tendue dans le
jeu de 0,4 qui soudent sur la plateforme
bleu puis rejoint rouge à l'aide d'une
jeune je rejoins la planète une jeune
puis rejoint leur hôtel et sexuelle puis
rejoint la bleue écoutons numéro c'est
bon là je pense qu'on s'est fait un
second prix attention ces sites ou de
requêtes qui tournait trop long du lot
nouri j'ai dit le moment déjà mais
violet gagne le tournoi si tu avais la
vidéo tu peux cliquer sur j'aime juste
là me rejoindre sur facebook ou sur
twitter c'est gratuit tout ça pas de
souci d'un centre bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo
moi je sais pas mais au bout d'une heure
un jeu comme ça déjà cet arrivage
bonheur je te fais ici this is it que
vous êtes le bug on y retourne